[موسيقى]
مساء الخير على حضراتكم حلقه جديده من
حلقات افكار الاستاذ استاذنا الدكتور جوده
عبد الخالق لكن هذه المره سوف تكون مخصصه
للاجابه على اسئله حضراتكم انا الحقيقه
حصرت الاسئله وهي كثيره جدا في اول 23
ساعه فقط ثم ان شاء الله نستانف حصر مزيد
من الاسئله اللي ه يعني تتوالى تباعا ان
شاء الله لطرحها على معالي الدكتور مساء
الخير معالي الدكتور مساء الحريه ربنا
يخلي حضرك التحيه الجديده انت عنها
بالنسبه للمعطيات اللي حو اي
صحيح انا انت عند حضرتك مهمه اتمنى تكون
ميسوره يعني كم كبير من الاسئله ولكن انا
قسمت المجموعات اسئله ده طابع دولي واسئله
تتعلق بالملف المصري واسئله تتعلق
بالمفاهيم اقتصاديه عامه اه لكن استاذن
حضرتك في سؤال عاجل عن مفهوم اليه التوريق
خصوصا في الحاله المصريه هل ممكن ان يكون
عمليه التوريق التي طرحت مؤخرا لبعض اصول
الدوله يكون مخرج لمصر على المستوى المؤقت
واستاذن انه اشير لان ده من نوع من
الامانه ان ان في هي ا طرحت من مجموعه من
من الشخصيات العامه ومنهم الاستاذ هاني
توفيق اللي كان ضيفي هنا دايما متبني
الفكره دي واخرين بيقول كده انه احنا
علينا عشرات المليارات واجبه السادات في
الامد القصير خصوصا في 24
و2 وانه رغم ان هو حماسه لقضيه الانتاج
ولكن ضروري جدا نلاقي حل سريع بان احنا
قناه السويس مثلا مثلا بتدر 10 مليار
فاحنا هنصدر
سندات بيه نستلف بمقتضاها واللي هيقت
هياخد بضمانات عائد هذا ما تاتي به قناه
السويس وغيرها من الاصول السياديه كاننا
بنضحي بح بضحي بعائدات القناه على المدى
البعيد في مقابل فلوس عاجله الان تسدد
الديون الملحه كيف ترى هذا المقترح ايه
اللي بقى التوريق اولا ايه هو وايه معناه
في الحاله المصريه وهل ده الحل ولا لا هو
ده سؤال التوريق معناه انك انت ا لديك اصل
من الاصول المولده
للدخل
ودخل يتدفق سنويا عبر فتره ممكن تكون لا
نهايه او لا نهايه ولكن نهايه بعيده شويه
و عليك التزامات حاله وتسعى الى مواجهه
هذه الامات الحله بالاستدانه بضمان هذا
الاصل هو ده الموضوع يعني
كلمه تويق كلمه شيك جدا اللي هي سكتشن
واصلا واحد من الابداعات بتاع الهندسه
الماليه كويس وكان احد اهم المداخل الازمه
الماليه العالميه اللي اندلعت سنه 200
بالمناسبه
يعني طيب انا بتيجي تقول حاله مصر بقى
نعمل ايه قالك اه انت عندك يعني اصول
انتاجيه مدر للدخل لفتره طويله ودخل معتبر
وبنادي الاجنبي خد قناه السويس
كمثال احنا نعمل ايه دلوقتي نصدر سندات
نقترض يعني ايوه تقترض بضمان هذا الاصل
بضمان العائد الذي سيتولد من قناه
السويس ويبقى في الحاله دي اكننا حولنا
الاصل الموجود ده الى ورقه
والورقه بنقدر نحصل بيها على سيوله حاله
وناجل عمليه الدفع لما بعد ده ده منطق
يعني بايجاز طبيعه
ما يحدث لجل عمليه الفع احنا هندفع احنا
هندفع احنا هنستغنى عن جزء من العوائد
المستقبليه مشل انت هتاخد الحصيله
بتاعه
السند اللي هو الورقه ديع ورقه كويس كده
انه انا ادخل السوق العالمي اطرح سق وورقه
سند عظيم بنسميه
سكيورتي ورقه ماليه هذه الورقه الماليه في
ناس هتشتريها وتشتريها ليه لانه بتدر عائد
مجزي
ومعتبر وبعدين استخدم انا الايرادات
المتولده عن هذا الاصل الذي املكه لسداد
الالتزامات القائمه على هذه الورقه مظبوط
ف دول مستوين للموضوع وده سليم
بشرط انك انت لسبب ما لسبب ما قد تعجز عن
السداد وفي هذه الحاله سيتم الرجوع على
الاصل نقطه مهم مهمه جدا جدا يعني دلوقتي
في ديون مصر الحاليه خ عشان بد المقارنه
تم بين يعني حاله ما فيش توريق وحاله
التوريق حاليا ما فيش توريق اح ماشيين
وزاره التعاون بتعمل قروض معه وبناخد قروض
كلام من ده انما لا يوجد اصل من الاصول
الضامنه ا لهذا الدين وبالتالي ا لما تبقى
الامور على المحاك لا يستطيع الدائن ان
يضع يده على اشياء محدده انما بيتكلم على
علاقه دوله بدوله تخضع لمفاوضات اعاده
الكلاله زي ما حصل على خلفيه مشاركه مصر
في حرب الخليج اللي هي حرب اخراج العراق
من الكويت سنه 1990 عظيم ف عفيت من ديون
مظبوط فهنا سؤال طيب لو انك انت عملت اصل
ايه بقى توريق لايه بالضبط تبص اصولك
الانتاجيه وتطلع سندات بضمان هذه الايه
هذه الاصول هو ده معنى غير كده مابيبقاش
توريق اه الاصول الانتاجيه عندنا احنا
اوضح م قناه السويس الاصول قناه السويس
وايه
تاني تتكلم بقى لو تتكلم على منشات
انتاجيه معينه لها اهميه ممكن انك انت ت
مثلا انا بسمع يقوللك السياحه ايه السياحه
السياحه ديت شركات عامه وشركات خاصه
معظمها شركات خاصه يقوللك تحويلات
العاملين ازاي ينفع اصدر سند بتحويلات
العاملين يعني في الخيال المالي ممكن ولكن
على ارض ايو
طبعا دي اموال اخرين بتاتي الى البنك انا
اصدر بها ايه اصلا اصلا مين اللي هيصدر
السند في الحاله دي الحكومه اه الحكومه
المصريه لا تملك اموال المصريين العاملين
بالخارج دي دي اموال ملك اصحابها وبالتالي
في صحيح القانون في مغالطه هنا انه انا
انا بتكلم
كحكومة وبالتالي ممكن انها تعمل عمليه
توريق استنادا الى هذا الاصل تمام يعني من
الناحيه النظريه مافيش مشكله على الاطلاق
انما موضوع تحويلات العاملين مستحيل لان
تحويلات العاملين يعني انت ما انت دلوقتي
بتقترب بتقترب من غير فكره التوريق على
امل ان في المستقبل هيجيلك تحويلات منين
العاملين وتستخدم
الحصيله بدلها بالنيه تديهم جنيه تاخد
دولار وتسدد اللي عليك مظبوط ده الوضع
انما عمليا بقى عمليا هتظر السك على ايه
الاصل الانتاجي الاصل الانتاجي هو ايو
الاصل الانتاجي هو البشر ملايين المصريين
بيشتغلوا في الخارج مش معقول ان في راي
يعني يصل نوع
من انا مش عايز استخدم تعبير ماحبش
استخدمه
لكن يعني كده في بد بال الشديد خلل في
التفكير الشديد تمام فده وارد في حاله لو
لقينا امثله ثانيه انا يحضرني لان لو انا
انا يحضرني يعني واضح من من فهمي للقصه
انه قناه السويس اصل هو الاوضح لكن ممكن
ينطبق على اي مؤسسه بتدر عائد منتظم تملكه
الدوله نيابه عن الشعب شركات تكون شركات
بترول شركات غز شركات منسوجات ايا كان انا
مش عارف اسماها شركات الاوتيلات والفنادق
التي تمل الدوله ولكن دي عندها مشكله لان
الدوله بتابعها على فكره اوكي انا بس اقول
انه يعني برض احنا تاريخنا بيدينا امثله
لهذا ولابد ان نعود الى هذا التاريخ ونشوف
في القرن 19 في الواقع كان شركات الرهن
العقاري بتعمل كده ب تعمل توريق ده بتتكلم
على امريكا والعالم وهنا كان بيعملوا ده
امتى ده في القرن 19 قرن 19 ايوه وفي
الواقع كان هذا سبب اندلاع زمات طحنه جردت
ملاك الارض المصريين من ملكياتهم وتحولت
الى الشركات اللي قدمت الايه القروب بتاعه
الرهن العقاري معلش ممكن تفهمنا لان دي
مساله معلومه جديده عليا معرفش يعني اه
شوف القرن 19
كان ترعرع للناس اللي بيتكلموا على الفتره
الذهبيه والكلام
ده نشاط شركات اساسا غربيه او يملكها
غربيين للرهن انجليزيه وفرنسيه وبل
للرهن العقاري ذلك يقول لك ايه فلان
الفلاني عايز يستصلح ارض مثلا يعني يبقى
عشان استاذ محتاج تمويل ندي له تمويل
بضمان الايه الارض طيب هو هينتج هينتج قطن
القطن معرض للدوره دوره الاعمال
الخارجيه فلما حصل مثلا في السنوات الاولى
من القرن العش ازمه كبيره في هذا
المجال ثمن القطن انخفض انخفاض كبير جدا
اصبح ما يرد من تصدير القطن لا يكفي لسداد
التزامات قبل الدائنين فهنا جت فكره
التوريق انك انت عامل القرض ده بضمان
الايه بضمان
الارض ترجع للتاريخ ده تجد
انه يعني مثلا انا بس الذاكره مش سعفان
لان اقوللك على بعض الكتب كل الكتب اللي
اتكلمت على تاريخ مصر الاقتصادي في القرن
19 جمال سعيد وغيره ويتكلموا على على هذه
على هذه الجزئيه دي التجربه الاولى
التجربه الثانيه في القرن ال
20 لما كان يوسف بطرس غالي وزير ماليه ناس
كتير ما تعرفش الكلام ده يوسف بطرس غالي
اصدر في ت من قريب في عاد الرئيس مبارك
مظبوط في التسعينات اصدر نوعين من
السندات نوع لاجل خمس سنين ونوع لاجل 10
سنين وكان بسعر الفايده اعلى من سعر
الفايده في السوق العالميه
وكان تفسيره او تبريره للكلام ده انه احنا
بنحط بنش مارك يعني بحط خط اساس لمصر في
ساحه التمويل الدولي عشان لما ندخل نقترض
يبقى عاملين لنا سمعه عارف على فكره دي
فكره امريكاني بالدرجه الاولى انا مره
عشان الناس بتعرفوا حاجه لطيفه
جدا قلت في حاجه اسمها مؤسسات لل التصنيف
الائتماني طبعا فانا اديت معل ولت عايز
اشوف يصنفون ائتمانيا ازاي طلع تصنيفي زي
الزفت عارف يعني انا لا اؤتمن انت قدمته
لهم بياناتك يعني اه بقوللك ق لنا كذا
وكذا وكذا وهو يعمل الحزبه ويبعت لك بتاع
فرحت نكلمهم قلت لهم ايه يا جماعه الموضوع
ق التفسير الوحيد ايه لا انت عمرك ما
اقترضت يعني تصنيفك الائتماني سيء لانك لم
تقترض لان ما اقترض خ بال فتالي يوسف ب
قاللك انا عشان ارفع تصنيف الائتماني لازم
اقتر انما الظريف بقى اتصالا
بموضوعنا
حقيقه انه
ال السندات اللي زارتها مصر لما كان يوسف
بوط غالي وزير ماليه الخمس سنين والعش
سنين كانت بضمان البترول اه اه طبعا مكتوب
كده بضمان البترول وبتال صت مصر من
البترول المملوك للدوله بالظبط كده طيب
هنا بقى معروف انه سعر البترول في سول
بيطلع و بينزل بيتقلب اه فلما يجي يحصل
انخفاض كبير في سو بتاع ده ايه اللي يحصل
انك انت قد تعجز عن السداد وفي هذه الحاله
نظرا لخلي بالك من الحزب الاقتصاديه
الشيطانيه نظرا لانخفاض سعر البترول وانت
لازم تسدد مبلغ معين فلما تضرب سعر في
كميه معناها لازم تصدر كميه اكبر من
البترول ا اه طبعا بس هو في القلب من هذا
الجدل هو النقطه اللي بتقول حضرتك عليها
هل كل توريق بضمان عائدات اصل من الاصول
مصنع مثلا ام واحنا بنفرق ما بين انه
الضمان هو الاصل المصنع المكن والعقار
المكان المنشا يعني وعائداته هل اذا تعثر
اي مصنع في سداد سند سداد يعني مستحقات
سند تمت عن طريق التوريق هل بالضروره يكون
الاصل هو الكوتريل هو الضمان اه بحكم بحكم
منطق التوريق
بس التوريق بيقول انا العائد من هذا الاصل
مش الاصل نفسه ولا مافيش فرق لا لا هو
ماليش دعوه بالعائد هو دلوقتي ايه الضمان
دلوقتي الضمان الاصل الضمان العائد من
الاصل لا انت يعني هو العائد من الاصل ده
بيجي منين من الاصل مش كده ولا ايه طيب
العائد من الاصل بيتوقف
لتقلبات السوق
الدوليه الاصل نفسه عباره عن انشاءات
وقدرات على ارض الواقع دي اللي يتحط ده
اللي هي في نهايه المطاف هي الضمان الضمان
ل
للمقرض عند عجز المدين عن الايه عن السداد
اذا حضرتك بتقطع تماما ان اي سندات تصدر
بضمان عائدات اصل من الاصول هي تعني
بالضروره انهه هذا الاصل سوف يكون معرضا
لخطر الاستيلاء عليه من الدائن في حاله
التع طب
اشارت اليه دي نقطه مهمه اصلها في في شق
نقدي وشق مادي اه الشق النادي هو العائد
اه اللي نتحدث عنه وهذا العائد يتوقف على
ا مقتضيات السو عالميا بتتكلم على شيء
يتداول عالميا ويتحدد له سعر مش كده
وبالتالي يدر حصيله بالنقد الاجنبي فاذا ا
مقتضيات السوق العالميه نتج عنها انه هذا
العائد انخفض انت كمدين عجزت عن السداد صح
فاذا العائد اللي بتتكلم عليه مش هيضمن
لان العائد لا يكفي هو ده لب المشكله
الضامن الحقيقي في نهايه الامر هو الاصل
الذي يولد هذا الايه هذا العائد والله هي
دي برده معلومه مهمه وكنت اتمنى بصراحه
كان يبقى لطيف جدا ان بعض انصار ال انا
كنت اتمنى كده كان حوار بديع جدا معانا
لانه انا احمل له كثير من الاحترام
والتقدير الاستاذ هاني توفيق ولكن هو كان
اقدر انا بقول الاستاذ هاني هو في اخرين
بيتكلموا بس انا بتكلم على من اعرفه وهو
الاعلى صوتا في ربما يكون له منطق اخر فكل
الاحترام لمنطقه كان يبقى مفيد جدا يعني
كان يبقى مفيد جدا ان احنا يعني نقارع
الحجه بالحجه لكن هو بس عايز اقول طبعا
انا زيك انا اقدر الاستاذ هاني قد اتفق
معه ولكن هو راجل مستقيم فكريا جدا
ا وامين كويس كده لا يناور
ا وبيننا
موده وبالتالي كان يبقى مفيد لو احنا عايز
بالمناسبه ديت الى ان يتاح لنا هذلك هناك
فرق بين الفكر المالي والفكر
الاقتصادي الفكر المالي والفكر الاقتصادي
الفكر الاقتصادي المالي هنا ربما هو اقرب
الى منطق اداره شركه خاصه تعاني من مشكله
سيوله ولديها اصول واحد الحلول ان ك تعمل
عمليه توريق للايه للاصل لما تنقل الموضوع
ده على الاقتصاد ودخل اعتبارات استراتيجيه
خلي بالك بتتكلم على قناه السويت بتتكلم
على تاريخ بتتكلم
على يعني بالمعنى
الجيوستراتيجي الرقبه ها للمجتمع فمن
الخطوره بمكان انك انت
تجازف وتمشي في سكه التوريق في وانا رايي
اذا كنت عايز تواجه مشكله الديون
على المستوى القصير الطريق الوحيد واعتقد
ممكن جدا تمشي فيه
اذا جنت الخبرات اللازمه واعاده
الهيكله يا جماعه نظره الى ما يسارع انا
بواجه ب اعاده هيكله الديون مظبوط واجال
ده معناها طبعا لها تكلفه انك انت تدفع
اكتر بعد كده ق يعرف الناس احنا عمالنا
عاده الهيكه دي في سنه
1990 في اطار برنامج التكيف الهيكلي تثبيت
وتكيف كلم مع مصر قد لا يعرف الناس انه
حتى الان لازال في ذمتنا احنا كمصر كمدين
دخل في عمليه اعاده هيكله واحنا بعد الحدث
ده ب 33 سنه من 90 ل 23
بتكلم مصر عليها التزامات تجاه الدائنين
بتوع نادي باريس حوالي 8 مليار دولار انا
عاوز اتاكد من ان انا فهمت مساله اعاده
الهيكله انا مفهوم اعاده الهيكله اصل
التعبير لطيف جدا انا احنا بنيجي كده على
مستوى الافراد انا مدير للدكتور جوده
بمبلغ 1000 فجا اخر الشهر اقول له انذرني
الى حين ما يصر فيقول لي بارك الله فيك
خلاص ما ابشر يعني المشكله خلصه لكن
الواضح ان المساله مش بالبساطه دي انا
عندي عشرات المليارات وجبت السنات على
الامن القصير حضرتك بتقول ان الحل العملي
هو اعاده الهيكله اللي حاولت تعمله دول
اخرى وتقول انا غير قادر فانا بدل ما هسدد
الدين الان اللي هو مثلا في 24 سوف اسدده
في 28 ولكن يعني امد الاجال بفائده اعلى
هل هذا المقصود عظيم جدا وده يتطلب
مفاوضات بس هل هل عايز المفاوضات
والمفاوضات لها اطار واليات وده ينطبق على
السندات المملوكه في السوق اللي هي مملوكه
لمستثمرين في السوق ده ممكن مثلا مع
السعوديه مع امريكا مع الديون السياديه مع
الصندوق مع البنك هو المميز هنا بين نوعين
مسميه لو انا كمدين الدي التي في ذمتي هي
في حكم الديون العامه بمعنى الطرف
الدائن دوله او جهه عامه حكومه او جهه
حكوميه او بنك في حكم المؤسسه الحكوميه
وده الوضع بالنسبه لمصر في الاغلب يبقى
الاطار هو ما يسمى نادي باريس كويس كده
يعني في في ناديين الديون العامه يعني اذا
كان الدائن عام يبقى الاطار نادي باريس
اذا كان الدائن خاص بنوك تجاريه انت دخلت
مثلا
قراض من زي مثلا في حال نميز بين حاله بلد
زي و طبعا بالتاكيد بتابعنا ناس من بلاد
مختلفه حاله الجزائر اه طبعا معظم ديون
الجزائر ديون خاصه بمعنى انها من بنوك
تجاريه بمسمى او اخر في الحاله دي الجزائر
اذا احتاجت تلجا الى نادي لندن اه نادي
لندن معلومه جديده دي يعني الديون
التجاريه اللي هي مملوكه للمستثمرين في
السوق مضبوط اشتروا علشان يستثمروا في انه
ياخ خد فايده اعلى ده نادي لندن ونادي
باريس للجهات السياديه اللي ينطبق عليها
الدول او صندوق النقد او البنك الدولي الى
اخره صح عظيم جدا فانا ممكن اتفاوض مع
نادي باريس او نادي لندن ايوه في حاله مصر
واحنا بنتكلم على التوريق كحل اه لا انا
بقول انك انت تقعد مع نادي باريس اعضاء
نادي باريس كام يا عم يعني ممكن يبقوا 40
طرف 30 طرف انما هم بيواجه وك ككتله واحده
خلي بالك يعني في في اليه المفاوضات
بيتكلموا في صوت واحد ولهم متحدث باسمهم
ما فيش ما تقدرش تضرب واحد مع التانيين اه
طبعا عندهم مجلس ادارتهم يعني مظبوط مظبوط
كده عمليه يعني مقننه ولكن انا بقول ايه
الوضع الحالي حاليا ان مصر اوكي تعرضت
لعدد من الصدمات الخارجيه في وقت واحد
تضبط الملف تشوف الصدمات دي ايه هي
ايه الاضرار اللي عادت على مصر من هذ اذا
انا بقول دلوقتي ده الكلام ده يا جماعه
بيدي عمر لا بيدي فانا دلوقتي بطلب بما ان
الموضوع لظروف خارج ارادتي انا بطلب
تقديرا للاوضاع ان احنا نعمل ايه بقى
ناخد ديون جديده اوكي نسدد بيها الديون
القامه سدد بيها ديون قائمه فهي مش بتعفي
من السداد هي بتديك براح من الوقت للسداد
وتسدد بيه فاصبح انت دلوقتي خلاص الديون
اللي كانت قائمه اتسدت اتدت وفي ديون
جديده ايه على امات بعيده بالضبط كده طبعا
في العمليه يقوللك ما المؤسسه ماليه في
النهايه وبوجه لدافع الضرائب وفي اسئله
وكلام من ده وبالتالي انت ستتحمل الهامش ا
اعلى لسعر الفائده بالنسبه للديون الجديده
بالمقرر لديون الليس ا الدول هتقول لك ان
انا دول عندي التزامات تجاه دافع الضرائب
اللي هم اقرك مضبوط طيب يبقى اذا الحل
الاول هو تفاوض مع نادي باريس الذي سبق
وان تفاوضنا معه مضبوط فيديني دين جديد
لسداد الدين القديم وانا بقى علي ان انا
ارتب اولوياتي واخد كل الاجراءات بقى
التقشف وكذا طب ونادي لندن ما يفيدني لا
لانه ديونك نادي لندن خصيصا للدائنين
الخواص اللي هم شركات خاصه بنوك مؤسسات
ماليه
خاصه انا حسب هيكل الدين المصري طبقا
لبيانات البنك المركزي الجزء الاكبر منه
في الواقع هو وفي جزء خاص اللي هو شركات
خاصه مقترضه من بنوك خاص ده دخل في الصوره
ليه لانه دين بالنادي الاجنبي فيبقى لازم
يدخل في الشبكه بتاعه البنك الايه المركزي
اه لا بس هنا في نقطه مهمه انا ممكن انا
ا ممكن الدوله نفسها الدوله نفسها مصر انا
بتكلم على الحكومه الديون السياديه الان
وال وال المؤسسات اللي هي تابعه للدوله بس
هي بتقول انا مستقله زي زي مثلا هيئه
البترول
وخلافه دول ا اقترضوا اما من دوله اقترضوا
من مؤسسه فده هيبقى نادي باريس لكن ممكن
كمان اقترضوا في السوق المفتوح يعني طرحوا
سندات في حالتنا قليله قليله حاله مصر
قليله نسبه ضعيفه جدا بس لو الدوله اشترت
من السوق ممكن تروح لنادي لندن ولا باريس
ولا ما تروحش لاي حد لو اشترت من السوق
بصفه غالبه زي ما ذكرت حاله الجزائر
لانعرفها كويس يبقى لازم تروح نادي ا نادي
لندن نادي لندن اذا كانت محتاجه اه لكن
حصرين واحنا نتحدث عن الحاله المصريه
بمناسبه ما طرح عن التوريق كم مخرج من من
مشكله الديون في حالتنا ان انا بقول ان ده
بينطو على مخاطر استراتيجيه كبيره وليس هو
الحل الحل ان انا اقعد مع نادي باريس واعد
الملف جيدا وادخل في تفاوض وطبعا ممكن
انتظر ظرف واكب ومناسب يساعدني انا هنا
بستغل بقى ايه الرع الجيو استراتيجي بتاعي
كما حرتها في حرب الكويت ايوه بعد حرب
الكويت اذكر الاصدقاء انه مصر كانت مديونه
فيما اذكر بحوالي يعني برقم كبير لكن هي
اعفيت من حوالي 18 مليار
دولار على ما اذكر يعني انا اشتغلت على
الملف شويه وده كان رقم كبير في التسعينات
وجاءت في صوره التالي يعني بضعه مليارات
يمكن سته او اكثر من دول خليجيه كانت تدين
لمصر فاعف مصر من الدين تقديرا لها على
دورها في مساهمه تحرير الكويت والولايات
المتحده اعفت مصر برض تقديرا لهذا الموقف
بالاضافه ان هي شجعت مؤسسات دوليه ان
هي صحيح تخفف من الدين تعفيها تجدوها مش
كده مظبوط يا معال الدكتور امريكا افتنا
من بنسبه 100% من ديون معينه وبنسبه 50%
من ديون ثانيه يعني التفاصيل بس لا اذكر
انما انا متاكد منه انه ديون مصر كان ديون
عسكريه وديون مدنيه تظيم ديون العسكريه
اعتقد تم اعفاء مصر بال بالكامل والديون
المدنيه بالنسبه 50% والديون العربيه
بالكامل بس كل ده لانه
استراتيجيا موافقه مصر على الانضمام
للتحالف الدولي ضد العراق دي مساله مهمه
جدا اللي بيسمعنا كانت حاسمه اه في ان
يقوم للتحالف قائمه ويحقق رض او لا تقوم
له قائمه ولا يحقق فك نوع من المكافاه وده
ممكن في
الفكر الاقتصادي بنسميه الريع الاستراتيجي
انك انت عندك موقع استراتيجي وماله وماله
في دول كثيره تركيا دول كثيره
بتستمر لا لا باس اذا الخلاصه فيما يتعلق
بالتوريق الذي يشغل الناس الان انك انت
كدكتور جوده تعتقد ان هذا خطر كبير وانك
تفضل بدلا منه او انك ترفضه انت مش لا
تفضل ترفضه وترى ان الحل على المدى على
المدى البعيد حضرتك اتكلمت كتير اعاده
النظر في الصوره كلها وتقشف وزياده انتاج
وا استعانه بكفاءات فانت اكلمت على الحلول
انت متهم بالاسراف كحديث عن الحلول
الطويله وكان ده عيب يعني انت متهم اصلا
بقضيه الانتاج في بعض التعليقات قت لي هو
الدكتور وكده مابيتكلمش غير على
الانتاج وكان دي تهمه ل انما على المدى
القصير حضرتك بتقول ان الحل هو الذهاب الى
نادي باريس انا هستاذن حضرتك في الحديث
لاحقا لانه انت اثرت فكره نادي باريس احنا
كدنا ننساها يعني ممكن نخصص لها حلقه
تانيه قوي قوي وانا درست الموضوع ده قبل
كده لانه في الكتاب اللي انا نشرته يبقى
في الحلقه الجايه نتكلم عنها نادي الريس
مع الدكتور تمام انا جزيل الشكر واستاذن
حضرتك نستانف في حلقه اخرى اسئله اخرى
مطروحه للشان الدولي والشان المصري
والمفاهيم الاقتصاديه خل بالك دلوقتي
بيضغط علينا لان احنا قربنا من رمضان وفي
حاجه اسمها فوازير رمضان فما فيش حد يبقى
دماغه اه هنسجل اكبر عدد من الحلقات ان
شاء الله قبل فوازير
رمضان جزيل الشكر معال الدكتور انا
بالمناسبه كنت عايز اقترح انه فظوره
الفوازير وكتبت تبقى ايه بقى لماذا نزعى
للاستهلاك عندنا اكبر نزع للايه
للانتاج في حين ان بلد زي الصين عندها
العكس تماما الصين معدل الادخار فيها فوق
ال 40% اه معدل الاستثمار حاجه و30 في
وبالتالي عندها فائض
باستمرار تراكم سنويا بدل ما يخلق ديون في
حالتنا بيخلق احتياطي ناد اجنبي والله
فزوره محتاجه محتاجه تفكير مش كده اه جزيل
الشكر معالي الدكتور جزيل الش الشكر
حضراتكم ونلقاكم في حلقات اخرى مع سلسله
حلقات افكار الاستاذ ب عبد الخلاء اشكركم
والى اللقاء